hey I bet you guys didn't knew that
today's world smile day now you do I'm
gonna be swift as like days that have
special things going on like today world
smile day who would have thought let me
tell you why it's world smile day which
this actually just blew my mind hold on
I'm reading this right from the internet
tardy Bell a commercial artist from
Massachusetts renamed the smiley face in
1963 how does one create a smiley face
because look at this this face is
smiling let me show you this like about
Harvey I know Harvey are you Harvey
either way thanks for for making us some
money I might know what makes you guys
smile I thought I would go around my
room and find random things that I
haven't it that make me smile I'm pretty
easily amused so things that make me
smile may not make you smile let's start
with what's on my desk
full Burnham's book definitely lots of
smiles lots of dick jokes that was a not
a joke when he said that there was a lot
of those in here xbox smile pumpkin
spice latte smile something that is not
a Mac smile call a duty anybody smile I
feel drunk clean laundry makes me smile
make a run a clean room makes me smile
but not really any smiles going on here
today pig pig pig kammo makes me smile
kammo kammo kammo my god
get off him up
well you're about hot a JJ Abrams's
makes me smile I mean look at this lens
flare like honestly I think that's worse
cuz my lens is dirty but you guys are
watching let me know what makes you
smile leave me some comments let me know
what you think about Harvey valve all
that I said vowel at the beginning is
ball
oh no he died in 2001 you can print your
own poster print print oh my god where
we gonna hang it where am I gonna hang
it here world smiled at a few an act of
kindness up one person smile we know if
you guys do a random act of kindness
today I plan on doing one I'll let you
know what it is on Twitter
peace out love you guys